WASHINGTON AND IT RELATES TO
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
WE HAVE TO TIE THIS TOGETHER FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
A COMMUNITY ROUTE, RAVAGED BY
LACK OF ACTION ON THE LOCAL AND
STATE GOVERNMENT THAT JUST
TURNED THEIR BACKS ON THEM.
VISALIA CALIFORNIA, OVER      OH
VISALIA CALIFORNIA, OVER      OE
COURSE OF TWO HAIL TO, THIS MAN
WENT ON A REIGN OF TERROR.
HE KILLED AT LEAST TWO AND
INJURED MANY MORE.
[GUNSHOTS]
>> DEPUTIES' HEARING GUNFIRE
FROM THIS MAN.
IT ALL WENT DOWN EARLY MONDAY
MORNING.
YOU CAN HEAR THE OFFICER
RELOADING HIS GUN AFTER THE
BULLETS RUN OUT.
>> Laura: THE CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE TRAGIC ON THEIR OWN BUT THE
RUN UP TO IT IS EVEN MORE SO.
TO DAYS BEFORE THIS REIGN OF
TERROR HE WAS ARRESTED BY THAT
TO LAHR COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPUTIES WERE BEING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF A CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE.
HE WAS HELD IN THE COUNTY JAIL
FOR ABOUT TEN HOURS BEFORE BEING
RELEASED EVEN THOUGH ICE
OFFICIALS               I.C.E.
OFFICIALS HAD ISSUED A HOLD.
HE HAD A VIOLENT CRIMINAL PAST.
>> THEY TELL FOX NEWS THAT
GARCIA HAD BEEN DEPORTED TWICE.
IN THE PAST THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE
COULD HAVE ALERTED IMMIGRATION
BECAUSE OF HIS EXTENSIVE RAP
SHEET WHICH INCLUDED ARMED
ROBBERY MORE THAN TWO YEARS AGO.
>> YOU MIGHT BE WONDERING WHY
THE COPS LET HIM GO.
WAS IT THE POLICE'S FAULT?
>> ICE DID FOLLOW A DETAINER AS
SOON AS IT LEARNED OF GARCIA'S
ARREST FRIDAY.
THIS WOULD BE ENOUGH TO KEEP
THEM IN CUSTODY IN OTHER STATES
BUT, THIS OFFICE NO LONGER
RECOGNIZES THOSE DETAINER'S AND
IT CAN'T REACH OUT TO I.C.E. FOR
MISDEMEANOR CRIMES.
>> SO OUR COUNTY SHERIFF SAID
BEFORE SP 54 WHICH IS THE
SANCTUARY STATE BILL, GUSTAVO
GARCIA WOULD HAVE BEEN TURNED
OVER TO ICE OFFICIALS, THAT'S
HOW WE HAVE ALWAYS DONE IT.
BUT AFTER SP 54 WE KNOW LONGER
HAVE THE POWER TO DO THAT.
WE SHOULD KNOW THE TWO
LARGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS VOTED TO ADOPT A
RESOLUTION OPPOSING CALIFORNIA
SANCTUARY STATE LAW IN MAY OF
THIS YEAR, AND EVEN THOUGH IT'S
KIND OF SYMBOLIC, IT DOES SHOW
CITIZENRY STANDING UP FOR COMMON
SENSE.
JOINING ME NOW IS MIKE
BOUDREAUX.
SHERIFF, I KNOW MY VIEWERS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE WATCHING
THIS AND WONDERING HOW THIS CAN
HAPPEN IN THE UNITED STATES
WHERE WE EMOTE MORNING, NOON,
AND NIGHT, ABOUT THE TRAGIC
CIRCUMSTANCES WHO ARE TRYING TO
COME INTO THE COUNTRY.
AND I GET IT, IT'S TRAGIC AND
IT'S TOUGH.
BUT DID YOU GET A CALL FROM
PELOSI OR FROM GAVIN NEWSOM?
ANY OTHER OFFICIALS IN
CALIFORNIA CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE?
>> YOU KNOW, THE ONLY PHONE CALL
THAT I GOT WAS FROM THE ACLU
DEMONIZING THE ACTIONS THAT WE
TOOK.
WHICH IS REALLY UNFORTUNATE.
YOU KNOW TO    TULARE COUNTY ISN
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY AND WE
PRODUCE MULTIMILLIONS IN
AGRICULTURE THAT SENT ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
WE HAVE A LARGE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY.
WE ALSO HAVE A LARGE GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO DON'T COMMIT THESE
CRIMES ON A DAILY BASIS.
I THINK WHAT OUR FOCUS IT ON IS
THE CRIMINAL.
THE CRIMINAL ELEMENTS THAT END
UP IN JAIL, AND I'M NO LONGER
ABLE TO RECOGNIZE THE DETAINER
THROUGH THE SANCTUARY STATE LAW
AS WELL AS THE NINTH QUART
CIRCUIT INDICATING THAT THE
DETAINERS DON'T MEAT DUE
PROCESS.
BECAUSE OF THOSE COMBINED
EFFORTS WE KNOW LONGER CAN
TELEPHONE I.C.E. AND EVEN ASKED
THE QUESTION, WHY IS THIS
DETAINER PLACED.
NOR CAN WE RECOGNIZE THE
DETAINER ITSELF.
>> Laura: CAN YOU GIVE THEM A
HEADS UP?
CAN YOU CALL AND SAY, WE ARE
ABOUT TO RELEASE THIS
INDIVIDUAL, OR WE HAVE THIS
INDIVIDUAL IN CUSTODY.
EVEN IF THEY CAN'T, AND
INTERVIEW HIM OR EXAMINE HIM, IS
THERE ANY NOTIFICATION AT ALL?
>> WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO TALK TO
OUR COUNTERPARTS.
>> Laura: I HAVE TO PLAY
SOMETHING FOR YOU.
THIS IS NANCY PELOSI'S CLAIM
ABOUT WHAT SANCTUARY POLICIES
ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISH.
WATCH.
>> ARE A CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IS A SANCTUARY CITY AND WE SEE
IT AS A PLACE WHERE IT MAKES IT
SAFER.
IT MAKES US SAFER BECAUSE PEOPLE
CAN GO TO SCHOOL, THEY CAN GET
DRIVER'S LICENSE, THEY CAN BE
WITNESSES AGAINST OTHER VIOLENCE
THAT THEY SEE IN THE COMMUNITY.
>> Laura: IS YOUR COMMUNITY
FEELING SAFER TONIGHT?
>> THEY ARE NOT FEELING SAFER.
BUT WE ARE NOT AGAINST OUR
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES.
I THINK IT NEEDS TO BE VERY
CLEAR, EVEN OUR UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY, THEY ARE NOT AFRAID
OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> THAT'S A LIE, EVERY TIME WE
DEAL WITH ONE OF THE SANCTUARY
POLICY CASES.
WE DID THIS IN NEW JERSEY A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
THE ADVOCATE THAT CAME ON SET UP
WE WILL NOT HAVE IMMIGRANTS
COOPERATING WITH AUTHORITIES, WE
WON'T HAVE AUTHORITIES
TESTIFYING IN CASES, THAT'S JUST
A BUNK.
SO YOU DON'T SEE THAT AT ALL?
>> WE SAY OUR COMMUNITY REACHING
OUT TO US.
WHAT THEY ARE AFRAID OF IS THAT
THE CRIMINAL WILL RETURN TO THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
REPORT THEM TO LIFE.
>> AND CREATE OTHER OFFENSES